what is connectivity in a screenplay and
why is that important
i feel like that to me at least the
connectivity seems like it would go with
uh like plot holes
sort of thing like filling it because uh
a lot of new writers
when they're writing stuff aren't really
looking at it as a whole they're just
doing like scene by scene by scene by
scene by scene and not realizing when
there are things that happen here
that you never set up over here so it
kind of feels like it's out of left
field you know like the
the the big thing is having like you
know twist endings and stuff like that
well twist ending doesn't work if you
didn't set it up
in in advance uh it'll just feel
completely out of left field
you know so it to me at least that's my
understanding of
from the question you know with that is
is being able to connect
the different aspects of the thing to
make it make sense because if you don't
have
the setup then the payoff doesn't work
you know or if you do a setup and then
there's no payoff well now you just
ruined the perfectly good setup and
people are gonna be mad why didn't
this come to fruition you know right
okay so so
just like turn of events different
things it can't just happen where there
was nothing to
set something off yeah like i said the
twist doesn't work if there's no
no setup if otherwise it's just a twist
for the sake of having a twist and that
never works well right do you think that
it's best though that the audience
didn't see the twist coming i mean in
terms of
the audience likes to know something
even even in a movie where there's like
a twist that you never saw coming
there's usually something in it
that if you were to go rewind it and
watch it again like then you'll see
oh that was already set up in advance
sort of thing you know
um i feel like in a movie if it's going
forward
and then the ending like is completely
bizarro and had nothing to do with
anything like i feel like i'm cheated
that feels like a huge like deus ex
machina sort of situation to me of like
there's no way this would have happened
why did this suddenly happen you know
but if there's things that set up i just
read so
i i read through a lot of the like the
blacklist scripts and i just read one
that was on 2019 blacklist
where the ending is kind of a twist
ending but it's something that
that if you paid attention got set up a
few pages at least prior so it wasn't
like
way at the beginning it got set up but
um and like the twist ending
in it was that it's about a mountain
climber who
she's climbing up this mountain and it's
like haunted mountain
and at the very end of it i don't know
if there's gonna be a spoiler because i
don't
as far as i know it hasn't got picked up
anywhere yet so in five years from now
it may be picked up and i apologize for
spoiling it five years in advance
um but she gets at the end like as she's
climbing
um when she gets to the very tip top it
turns out that now she's
like a part of like a heavenly sort of
situation and then it
suddenly jumps to work find her dead
body like in the cave below
um and it's kind of twisty because it's
like also okay she got the claw
what she was dead but it sets it up
because there's a couple different times
when she falls while climbing the
mountain and like
miraculously got saved especially the
very last one when she falls and one of
the ghosts
catch her is like at that point okay
she's still
plummeting when he caught her but it
makes it look like or um
what's the one with mandy moore in the
sharks uh oh
four four seven meters yeah let's try
that again right so
47 meters with manny moore you know like
the and i
apologize again for spoiling stuff but
at the end of the thing you find out
that like
a lot of the rest of the a lot of the
end of the script like
never happened like she gets saved and
we find out that
oh she's actually been imagining this
whole thing the whole time about her
having this final encounter with the
shark getting out of the cage
getting rescued coming up on the ship
and they do a really cool way
you know she had gotten like injured
along the way and when she's on the ship
her blood is like floating in the air
above her
and she's like watching it and then it
cuts down to her still being
in the shark tank and but they set that
up it because of the whole thing of of
um like hypoxia and
and and running out of oxygen so you
know it starts to like mess your head
hallucinating and stuff that was one of
the first things they talked about in
the movie
you know it was like the dangers of
being at such a low depth
you know of if you can't come if you
don't come back up in time
and they even talked about it again
while she was in the tank with her
sister before her sister like got killed
and stuff
by the shark that they were discussing
it again so it's like it suddenly got
set up twice
before we saw the ending so some people
you know watching and something like
what she
imagined that that's a horrible but no
it wasn't because they set it up twice
before then
so we kind of saw that it was a
possibility of her hallucinating so that
sets up
oh if she could hallucinate then yes
that makes sense for hallucinous ending
it kind of infuriates the audience still
because oh i wanted her to survive and
she's not gonna
but it sets it up so the twist works did
you see strange but true with margaret
quality
i don't believe so it was an adaptation
i think it came out last year and
that one was a shocker and then when you
write when you go back there were a few
clues
yeah i don't want to give i mean such a
great film um
it's a dark well you know the one that
everyone keeps go always goes to with
the twist ending you know is uh
sixth sense like if you paid attention
you could find that you could figure out
you know
or if even if you didn't figure out if
you rewind it watch the second time
you'll find all the different clues
along the way that bruce willis is
a ghost the whole time you know um
there's it's a lot of like little
minor things the you i didn't catch it
the first time i watched it most people
didn't
and people were like what that doesn't
make sense i rewatched a second time
like oh
here's where it's set up for it here's
where it's set up for it here's the
here's two scenes in a row where it sets
up for it so you know
it worked because there were setups like
you don't you didn't realize it along
the way but then
it's one of those things that like you
look back on it and find out the movie
is much better
than you actually realized that while
you were watching it sort of thing
yeah you like him not shyamalan oh yeah
i
know a lot of people give him [ __ ] for
someone yeah i don't know why but
um the only movie of his i didn't like
was the happening
uh with the one where the trees are
killing everyone okay
that was the only one that i thought was
like two out there um
but like i i'm a huge fan of his stuff i
i really want to see the servant
on apple tv plus i haven't gotten a
chance to watch it yet
there's i actually want to see most of
the shows in apple tv plus i'm just like
itching to
to to watch those um put it on the
vision board yeah
basically another what seven eight bucks
a month or whatever it is
i know but no this vision board is
getting expensive now all right
you don't have the coffee expense right
yeah
that adds up so so your book 365 a year
of screenwriting tips
which is beautifully displayed behind us
and then you also have a copy there
now i think you said first off to begin
the purpose
of the book is not to try and make you
better at a specific thing
right um so a lot of screenwriting books
will focus on one specific thing
you know um there's a book uh
oh what is it shadow something
it's a very good book i can't remember
what it's called the plug it for him um
but it's it's all about characters and
how to write characters specifically
villainous characters um then you have
you know like blake snyder's you know
save the cat that everyone loves and
stuff that tells you like how to outline
a story basically and like how
story beats work and then you have
you know books that are like either like
specifically about
television writing stephen l sears a
prolific tv writer he
he was the executive producer on xena
warrior princess
he's got a book that's just about tv
writing and and it
covers you know like how to come up with
ideas and also some of the business
stuff which is why it's a very good book
because it
goes over the business stuff that a lot
of other things skip and pass on
and so my book has like it's not about a
specific thing it's kind of like a
general overall
arc of writing um
the process of writing the business of
writing what you can expect
um you know i've got it broken down into
different parts if i can
get to the table of contents so we've
got like the before you start which is
you know talking about
um some of the misconceptions about
writing in general
uh it talks about you know like like you
said before about like the the
statistic that there are nfl football
players and there are screenwriters
uh then there's like a bit on writing
and there's prep work uh which is you
know about outlining and and
treatments and and how to come up with
ideas uh there's a section on format so
instead of being a whole book about
format you've got one section here
that's what uh
40-ish pages on formatting and each of
the
each of the things are only like a page
or less each you know so
um it's all very quick reading um
there's a thing specifically on story
think of characters dialogue thing on
rewriting and then
after what to do after the script is
done and there's so it covers a little
bit on everything
but it's not it's not made to make you a
better writer it's
more of to know about the writing
process
what to do before and after how to get
your head in game and come up with ideas
and stuff like that it also has ideas on
how to relax
um you know i've gotten there one of the
tips is about having a positivity
calendar because it is very difficult to
stay positive
in this industry when you're getting
rejections coming at you from everywhere
um so my positivity calendar is is you
get your calendar instead of checking
the calendar off with
x's like they do in the movies uh i mark
off the days in the calendar by writing
every positive thing that happened to me
that day oh that's great
so then later on if i have like a really
bad rejection
or like really wanting this meeting and
then it fell through
instead of being like being alone i can
look back at the calendar oh well
okay yes today didn't wasn't so great
but look at all this amazing
stuff that happened to me earlier on in
the week and stuff you know
or and yeah it's a good way to keep kept
track of your progress
like i also put in there like my pa
what page i ended on on my different on
my scripts each day so then i can also
keep track of my progress
like that's a positive thing i i got
yesterday i was on page 23
today on page 34. awesome i wrote you
know a bunch of pages today
you know and another tip in there is uh
relax
go if you're in los angeles go to salt
and straw get yourself some ice cream
because it's fantastic ice cream
i know where's that by the way they have
a bunch of locations
um they're originally from oregon i
believe
um and then they've they've got uh
in portland they've got like a couple
locations they're not here in la they've
got i think
five locations in la there's one on
third street in downtown
uh the only reason i don't suggest
something else is nowhere to park in the
in the arts district um there's one on
larchmont there's one on
ventura uh like up in in noho area um
there's one
in uh venice um there's one on
santa monica boulevard uh there's one
uh in um downtown disney now oh no just
opened uh
last year i think and then they've got a
couple locations i think
there's one location two locations down
in san diego so like all along the west
coast they've got salt and shawn
oh san francisco they just opened a san
francisco one too so
basically everywhere along the west
coast uh
it's fantastic ice cream and they they
change their flavors every month they
they have some really good fun they have
some really bizarre ones too like uh
in april last april for the spring i
think they had one that had uh chocolate
covered bugs in it
oh wow so it was a grass-flavored ice
cream with chocolate covered bugs
um for halloween they had a blood
pudding one that
the main base actually was chicken blood
and livers
yeah but then they also have you know
like they all they have regular flavors
too
okay do they have they have chunky they
have like chocolate stuff you know and
they have um right now for february they
have
you know a chocolatier series where all
the flavors are
based on like a local chocolatier
company like
if you're in la it's like all la
chocolate companies
um you know like like the comparte and
um
31 blackbirds and stuff like that where
they make the ice cream based on those
san diego
portland they all have like their own
local chocolatiers that they change
their
their recipes for so uh one year they
had um
i don't know why i'm talking about ice
cream so screen writing i'm sorry
i'm sorry
you